i could have an idea in my head for five
six seven years all right and i've kind
of little by little been working out
different things about it the day that i
sit down to do it
whatever is going on with me at the time
will find its way into the piece it has
to or the piece isn't worth making all
right an analogy i always use because
all of my writing techniques i never
took any writing classes or seminars or
anything like that read any pamphlets my
whole thing was um everything i learned
as an actor studying acting for six
years i've basically applied to writing
if i was writing the guns of the
navarone all right and then right in the
right at the beginning of writing it or
in the middle of writing it i i break up
with my girlfriend who i'm like madly in
love with and then my heart is is is
shattered all right that's gotta work
into it now the story is still about a
bunch of commandos going to blow up a
couple of canons all right but that pain
that i'm feeling has got to find its way
into this story or else
what am i doing